PENNSYLVANIA AND KARI LAKE WHO
WANTS TO BE GOVERNOR OF ARIZONA.
WE ARE A NATION OF ACTIONS OR AT
LEAST WE USED TO BE.
WE USED TO ALL AGREE THERE WAS A
PROBLEM.
BUT AS A NORMAL DEMOCRACY WE
WOULD DISAGREE ON WHO WAS THE
RIGHT PERSON TO FIX THE PROBLEM.
BUT NOW WE HAVE TROUBLE AGREEING
THERE IS A PROBLEM.
PRESIDENT BIDEN ALWAYS GETS ME
THINKING.
>> -- PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA
WAS ON THE TRUMP' AND HE ALWAYS
MAKES ME THINK.
>> REMEMBER WHEN THE OTHER GUY
WAS IN CHARGE AND CRIME WENT UP?
YOU NEVER HEARD ANYTHING FROM
THESE FOLKS.
BRIAN: WHEN IT COMES TO THE
BORDER OBAMA TOOK ACTION.
HE MADE EFFORTS TO DEAL WITH THE
NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
COMING IN.
THE REPUBLICANS WANTED MORE
DEPORTATIONS AND LESS TALK OF
AMNESTY.
BUT TRUMP MOVED PEOPLE IN
CHARGED TO FIX THE PROBLEM AND
PRESSURES R -- PRESSURED OTHER
COUNTRIES TO DO THEIR PART.
IN CHOOSING CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTIONS CHIEF PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS SIGNALING BORDER
SECURITY IS HIS TOP PRIORITY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT.
BRIAN: HE DID WHAT I WANT TO DO
TO GET THE BORDER PROTECTED.
EVEN IF IT MEANT MOVING MONEY
AROUND WHICH TICKED OFF
DEMOCRATS.
>> HE HAS AN OBSESSION WITH
FORCING TAXPAYERS TO SPEND
MONEY.
BRIAN: OFTENTIMES THEY FLAT-OUT
DENIED.
>> WE HAVE A SECURE BORDER.
BRIAN: YEAH, RIGHT.
VIOLENCE IN CHICAGO RAGED OUT OF
CONTROL.
TRUMP TOOK ACTION TWEETING THIS.
I WILL BRING UP THE MILITARY FOR
THIS NATIONAL EMERGENCY, SMELL
BE STOPPED.
NOT EVERYBODY WAS HAPPY WITH
THIS.
THE BENEFIT COULD BE DEBATED.
BUT THE INTENT WAS NOT.
HE WAS TRYING TO FIX THINGS.
PAST PRESIDENTS TRIED TO FIX
THINGS.
UNLIKE DEMOCRATS RIGHT NOW IN
BLUE STATES WHO DON'T SEE
ANYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
>> THE DATA SHOWS THAT SHOOTINGS
AND MURDERS ARE DOWN IN OUR
STATE BY 15% IN NEW YORK CITY.
SAFER CITIES ARE DEMOCRATIC
STATES.
BRIAN: THE SHARP RISE IN TOTAL
CRIME ACROSS THE CITY, ROBBERY,
RAPES, GRAND THEFT AUTO, DOES
THAT SOUND SAFE TO YOU.
LET'S LOOK AT OIL AND GAS
PRICES.
MOST AMERICANS ARE STRUGGLING TO
FILL THEIR TANK AND IMPORTANTY
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO GET HEAT
FOR THEIR HOMES THIS WINTER.
>> OIL COMPANIES RECORD PROFITS
TODAY ARE NOT BECAUSE THEY ARE
DOING SOMETHING NEW OR
INNOVATIVE.
THEIR PROFITS ARE A WINDFALL OF
WAR.
BRIAN: IS THAT SOLVING A
PROBLEM?
IS THAT A PLAN?
I THOUGHT WE COULD ALL AGREE
INFLATION WAS A PROBLEM.
BUT TO JOE, NO.
>> PRICES ARE RETURNING TO WHERE
THEY USED TO BE.
IT'S A TRANSITORY FIX.
TODAY WE RECEIVED NEWS THAT TOUR
ECONOMY HAD ZERO PERCENT
INFLATION IN THE MONTH OF JULY.
BRIAN: IT'S INSANE.
AMERICANS EXPECT THEIR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF TO ADDRESS
THEIR PROBLEMS HEAD-ON.